hey everyone bandit here and today
marked the first of e3 2021 we had
presentations from ubisoft and gearbox
and one of the
highlights of the entire day was marion
rabbids
sparks of hope we got a really cool
teaser trailer and gameplay really quick
i want to break down the teaser trailer
and point out a couple of really cool
things that i was able to find so to
start off already this is a completely
different setup than the first mario
rabbids game we're in space
space wasn't a part of the first game at
all we have this really cool looking
bunny ship that our heroes are flying
around in and i can't help but notice
that it looks like the same technology
that beepo
is made of so maybe beepo made this or
oversaw
its creation whatever right off the bat
we are shown that our heroes are flying
off in the ship towards this
island-looking thing in space
on top of the island we can see what
looks to be trees
in autumn or fall this is important
because later on in the trailer we can
actually see that they go to this island
and not another island because of those
trees on top
moving very quickly right after we're
done with the space scene we are shown
mario sitting here looking at a
holographic info screen
on this info screen for the very astute
observers it's revealed that this
computer is decoding the dna
of something and it has identified luma
and
rabid dna which is completely in line
with the whole concept of combination
that was introduced in the first
game in the background we can see peach
and luigi
presumably helping to steer the ship on
those other consoles
and rabid peach sneaks up on mario for
you guessed it a selfie mario takes it
like a champ
looks back right as the computer has
identified both luma and
rabid dna in whatever it is scanning and
you know that it's identified them
because it gave them verified check
marks
which we all know are very hard to get
it takes a second
and then reveals what exactly it was
scanning and it is this adorable
yet slightly nightmare-inducing creation
of a
luma rabbid which is one of those things
that i didn't know that i needed in my
life until now luma rabbit flies around
takes rabbit peach's phone and then they
start getting an urgent transmission
the computer says vast energy anomaly
detected and then
reveals to them in a holographic version
of the galaxy which everybody reacts
surprised to
but then you see why it reveals to them
that they are
many other of these rabid lumas out
there in space just floating around
a second later after you see them the
lumas gets straight up
murdered by a giant red hand it scares
rabbit luma who then
flies backwards and it reveals that this
huge
faceless question mark tentacle monster
thing
was responsible for killing the lumas
which is a crime
okay mario agrees that it's a crime gets
mad and looks at luigi and luigi's like
yeah this is a thing to be mad about
the ship descends through some clouds
towards that island that they were going
towards
and because they have now identified
some monsters out in the galaxy they
start to suit up and
uh right up against the camera we can
see another rabid luma
one that is blue that we'll see again
here in just a second these weapons are
all completely new
and all appear to be different depending
on the characters mario gets some pretty
sweet dual wielding powers
and the ship lands while creatively
hiding all of the rest of the island
behind it
and this right here is what reveals to
us kind of how these lumas are going to
be used in game
so these rabid lumas are elemental as we
saw a blue one earlier
a i don't know star-powered one here and
then a
fire rabbit luma here in the gameplay
trailer we actually see this fire rabbit
luma create a meteor storm in a battle
so as we can deduce from these two
trailers
these rabid lumas are going to grant the
heroes
powers and they're going to be
interchangeable and then one of the
biggest
bombs of the entire trailer is dropped
right here and no i'm not talking about
whatever is outside this window here
which is
kind of ominous looking i'm talking
about rabid
rosalina who looks just completely done
with life rabid rosalina
already being in this ship is kind of
strange to me it implies that there was
an adventure that has happened
before the events of what we see here
and it also implies
very specifically and very importantly
that rosalina does exist
in this universe somewhere we just can't
see her yet
or can we hold on for a sec so mario
tells rabbit rosalina get off your lazy
butt let's go have an adventure
and they walk out of the ship see and
then here
the ice rabbit luma flies above raven
rosalina implying once again that these
rabid
lumas are elemental power-ups for our
heroes looking at the rest of this
island that they landed on
it does confirm that this was that
island they were headed towards at the
first of
the trailer see the red autumn-like
leaves on these trees
they match the red autumn-like leaves on
these trees so the heroes are walking
outside
ready for a fight they turn around and
boom this never seen before luma
tiger giant enemy thing lands on top of
their ship
preventing them from leaving until they
defeat it the enemy itself is really
interesting looking but i don't think
it's anything more than just a strong
base level enemy because in the gameplay
trailer we can see them
fighting one of these enemies right off
the bat also this enemy's eyes are red
which i think is important because
when the other enemies start showing up
behind our heroes
we can see that their eyes are also red
not only does this give me some
really eerie like mind control super
smash ultimate vibes but that's probably
exactly what's happening because
it is heavily implied that they work for
this giant
faceless question mark hooded figure
with tentacles now we just saw a couple
interesting things that i want to point
out in the first place this giant hooded
figure here has some really interesting
design
details going for it so the face is
hidden
this is important because i believe if
we could see the face of this enemy
it would be
impactful i think it's possibly somebody
that we know and that goes a little bit
deeper than just
pure speculation you see this star right
here stars in this specific trailer
represent lumas i mean every time we've
seen a star before here we've got luma
plushie
rabid luma we've got several other rabid
lumas even out in space
we've got rapid rosalina with a luma
plushy and we have proof that this
evil being wants to kill these other
lumas
so this evil being star right here seems
to give to at least to me a relation to
the lumas and to space in general and
speaking of space
the galaxy can be seen in the hoodie of
this tentacle
monster now to me this all points
towards the fact that we know who this
monster is
i think this monster is a corrupted
rosalina i know that sounds crazy but if
you think about it
they did foreshadow rabid rosalina here
right before showing off this big enemy
and the fact that they showed rabid
rosalina at all
wanting you to think rosalina's in this
game and then didn't show you the face
of
a very titular character to the game
also implies to me
that this is probably rosalina also the
relation to loom is that this hooded
enemy seems to have
both wearing a star and wanting to go
around killing them in the universe and
the trailer doesn't go on for much
longer
the heroes to strike a pose and then
zoom off to do battle with
said monsters but personally i think
that given what we already pointed out
about this monster here and the fact
that in ubisoft's actual presentation
the producer of this game i believe said
that
the fusion of the rabid lumas is what
this game is actually going to be
about i think personally that it's all
centered around the lumas right the
galaxy it's all centered around rosalina
the final weird thing about the teaser
trailer and the gameplay trailer
is this little character right here with
the green black hair
in the gameplay trailer this character
here wields a big old sword but
for the life of me i can't remember or
think
of a green and black-haired character
that wields a sword in the mario
franchise so i have no
idea if that is a known character fusion
as well either way though lots of stuff
to be excited about lots of stuff was
revealed and lots of questions
still need to be answered based on the
trailers that we have here if you
haven't played the first game yet i
highly highly recommend it it is
extremely fun and i can only assume that
this game branches
off of what the other game already put
in place if you enjoyed this little
analysis
slash slight theory leave a like below
and also subscribe to stick around for
much more content to come
we are in the middle of e3 finally after
a year off
so i'm going to be doing analyses and
reactions and theories as i see fit so
make sure you're subscribed to stick
around for all of that also for my
regular viewers
hi i'm back i had a wonderful vacation
also this is the
end of the video so uh as always i hope
you have a wonderful rest of your day
this is mazatunabanit signing out and
looking forward to seeing you in the
next one peace
[Music]
you